right from the beginning of one piece we
are being told that the Marines are the
greatest enemies for pirates and a
massive obstacle for Luffy becoming
pirate king to put it simply Pirates
want absolute freedom and change while
Marines want control and stability and
so Luffy's path to becoming a Legendary
Pirate is full of battles with the
Marine organization however during this
mini Arc about Luffy's childhood it's
actually explained to us that his
grandfather who raised him instead of
his parents and who is one of the most
powerful and famous Marines in the story
always wanted Luffy to follow in his
footsteps now in the end Luffy of course
chose to follow in the footsteps of
Shanks instead quickly becoming a pirate
and a prime target for the Marine but
that still leaves a very interesting
question on the table what if Luffy
never got inspired by Shanks What If
instead of a pirates Luffy had become a
Marine so our story starts during
Luffy's childhood where he originally
got inspired to become a pirate in the
first place of course we could simply
assume here that Luffy never meet Shanks
in the first place however I think we
still want Luffy to eat his devil fruit
that Shanks brought with him instead
Luffy needs someone else to be inspired
by before Shanks ever arrives on his
Islands so for our specific scenario
here I want to assume that Luffy's
grandfather Garb brings along one of his
former students to visit Luffy the
Marine Admiral aokiji that's this guy
here with ice powers in the actual
storyline aokiti has always been
sympathetic towards Luffy he was relief
that Luffy took in Robin and allowed
Luffy and the straw hats to escape
multiple times basically throughout the
story we are being told that aokiji is
basically the ideal Marine who has a
fair sense of justice and truly cares
about the safety and the happiness of
the people so Luffy who badly needs a
role model sees him using his epic ice
powers and beat up some bad guys which I
think would be a great alternative to
Shanks now saying goodbye to Luffy's
grandfather Garb aokiji makes Luffy
promise to One Day become a great Marine
as well and so now Luffy's new goal is
not to become pirate King instead he now
wants to become the Marine Fleet Admiral
and with that we have the decisive
change in Luffy's story and from here on
out the rest of his childhood can stay
pretty much exactly the same training
with Garb Sabo and Ace Shanks then still
arrives at the islands Luffy still
befriends his entire crew and he still
eats his devil fruit because he gets too
hungry but what happens next is where it
gets really interesting before we can
talk about what happens with the other
straw hats and how the story overall
plays out from here I need to make two
assumptions about the main storyline
that are very likely to be true but
haven't officially been confirmed yet
assumption 1 is that GARP is a member of
sort in case you don't know sword is a
secret group within the Marines that
doesn't like how the Marines are being
controlled and used by the corrupt world
government of the one piece world and
instead want to create a much more just
and good Marine Corps and assumption 2
is that Shanks knows that Luffy is
important to change the world and that
Shanks wants Luffy to become pirate king
and find the one piece in case you're
already caught up to the manga and don't
mind spoilers I do have two videos
discussing both of these claims in
detail that you can watch later this one
and this one but for us right now it's
only important to know that Shanks
really tries to inspire Luffy to become
pirate king here but fails however even
though Luffy wants to become a Marine
thanks to Shanks he still very much
likes the idea of having a sort of crew
or team around him now skipping forward
to 10 years later Luffy sets out in his
small boat in exactly the same way as he
does in the main storyline however this
time his goal is not to find a pirate
crew but instead find a Marine base
where he can enlist into the Navy now
what's important to know here is that
he's still Luffy and he still has no
experience of sailing a boat so once
again he ends up in that Barrel on
alvida's ship here he saves Kobe and the
two of them end up in the exact same
town as before this time not to actually
look for Zorro and recruit him but to
join the Marines at the base in
however when Luffy sees Zorro tight in
the courtyard and talks to him he starts
to realize that the Marine captain and
his son here are terrible people and so
Luffy being Luffy I like to think that
he still takes an interest in Zorro and
decides to set him free even if it will
cost him his dream of becoming an
admiral and so after he beats up X and
Morgan once again he asked the Marines
if he Kobe and Zorro could still join
the Marines even though of course he
never discussed that with Zorro in the
first place now I think what would
happen here is that even though the
Marines of the base are actually really
thankful to Luffy like it happens in the
main storyline when more soldiers arrive
from the Marine headquarters to arrest
Morgan he tells them about Luffy's
attack on the base and as a result the
captain of the Squatch who just arrived
tells Luffy that even though he is
really grateful for what he just did he
can't let someone join the Marines who
attacked one of the higher ups when it
looks like Luffy has to give up on his
dream though to everyone's surprise GARP
is also on board of the ship however who
had come comes to pick up Luffy
personally and as we all know GARP isn't
someone that cares about the rules or
the higher ups at all and he just
decides to take all of them in as
recruits so now Luffy Zorro Kobe and
Palmetto are making their way towards
the grand line and Marine headquarters
on board of garb's ship there of course
he trains them really hard every single
day now remember GARP was able to teach
people like Kobe and helmeppo who are
really nobodies when he picks them up a
ton of super strong techniques in a
matter of months so just imagine how
fast Luffy and Zoro would grow under his
supervision next since Luffy and Zara
are not in need for a better pirate ship
this time though they never make it to
syrup village where they meet usup in
the main storyline and as a result
Captain Kudo can execute his plan to
plunder the village and usop is being
killed now Sanji however is a completely
different story and I do have to go on a
small tangent here usually Marine ships
have a unique ability that pirate ships
don't while all Pirates must enter the
grand line by going through reverse
Mountain Marine ships can actually cross
the so-called calm belt which is a strip
of Ocean between the grand line and the
normal ocean that has no wind and is
filled with giant sea monsters that sink
any ship that tries to pass through it
however the bottom of marine ships are
all coated in a special material called
sea stone that basically makes them
invisible to these monsters so they can
enter and leave the grand line when and
wherever they please and so GARP could
take them directly through the comb belt
to the Marine headquarters but I do like
to think that he would want to spend as
much time with his new recruits as
possible before showing them to the
fleet Admiral sengoku and the other
higher ups and also show his grandson
the world a little bit and so for our
scenario here I'm going to assume that
GARP would take the ship towards reverse
Mountain instead as a result they once
again would pass by the baratier on
their way to the Grand line again this
could go either way because Luffy really
needs to do some convincing to get
sanchi to join his crew in the main
storyline but I do like to think that he
would convince Sanji once again to see
the world with him and look for the all
blue as a marine this time meanwhile
Zoro would of course still get his epic
duel with dracul mihawk something the
other Marines are against but GARP
allows anyways because he just wants to
see what Zorro has to offer mihawk then
takes an interest in this Marine grunt
who is willing to sacrifice his life for
his honor as a swordsman now after that
there's of course also a real chance
that they never meet Nami and simply
pass by arlong Park however there are
two possible reasons why GARP would take
them there anyways maybe he just heard
about the corrupt Marines in the area
that arlong had paid off to leave him
alone definitely something that GARP
would do I think or maybe guard new
belmare which is nami's Foster mother
who was a former Marine soldier that
then found Nami as a a baby and was
later killed by arlong after all both
GARP and belmare were from the East blue
so he might have decided to visit her
grave on the islands and so in our
scenario Luffy Kobe helmeppo Zorro and
Sanji meet Nami and later find her
crying in the city plaza once again
Luffy takes them to arlong park and
beats arlong in memory of her mother
belmare and in order to draw a map of
the world Nami also decides to join GARP
Squad and help Luffy after that Luffy is
then promoted from grunt straight to
seaman first class for defeating a
powerful pirate which I think would be
quite similar to his 30 million Barry
Bounty that he gets in the main
storyline and the last stop before
entering the grand line is the loketown
where the group meets smoker who
immediately takes a liking to Luffy
smoker already started to like and
respect Luffy more and more in the
actual story despite hating Pirates so I
think he would vibe really well with
Marine Luffy right from the get-go and
while while Zoro is looking for new
swords to replace the ones that he lost
against mihawk Luffy runs into his
father Dragon who is having a tense
conversation with his grandfather and
then they finally answered the grand
lines through reverse Mount now here
they meet crocus who is a former member
of Goldie Rogers crew the first pirate
king crocus just as in the main
storyline of course knows about Luffy
from Shanks in the main storyline he
then helps the straw hats by telling
them about the final Island on the grand
line laughtail and by giving them the
lock pose which is a necessary Compass
sort of thing to navigate from Islands
to Islands in our version however crocus
is not of too much help he greets GARP
because they once fought together
against the legendary rocks pirate crew
many many years ago and he then tells
Garb that Luffy is special and should
have become a pirate as a result Luffy
doesn't even know about love tail yet
here afterwards the group of young
marines also encounters Vivi now GARP
who knows her father cobra the king of
alabaster recognizes her as the
country's princess and so under tears
Vivi tells them about crocodile and what
he has done to her country Luffy then
promises her to take her back home and
help her on the way there they stop at
drum Island because GARP has heard
rumors about Ace having been there
worried for his foster grandson who is
chasing after Blackbeard they ask in the
village if anyone has seen him Luffy is
not able to free drum Island from WAP
although because he is an official ruler
protected by the world government but he
does at least get to meet and recruit
chopper as well shortly after that they
then finally reach Alabaster where they
once again run into smoker to together
investigate what is going on with
crocodile when they finally meet him and
try to expose him the warlord laughs at
Luffy and Vivi that they can't do
anything and Luffy prepares to fight him
however GARP steps in to stop Luffy the
Warlords are part of the world
government and can't beat touched by
Marines Luffy will have to wait until
GARP reports this to sengoku and the
other higher-ups now as you can tell
Luffy at this point is probably starting
to get really frustrated and angry at
the Marine system for its unfairness at
this point clearly what is happening
here is bad and Luffy's just supposed to
let it go while traveling the country
Luffy quickly gets to meet Ace and then
his group runs into Nico Robin now GARP
has no other choice than arresting one
of the most wanted people in the world
when Luffy asks him for an explanation
GARP simply tells him to be quiet
however shortly after leaving Alabaster
they then run into Luffy's mentor and
hero aokiji who is biking on the ocean
just like in the main storyline aokiji
came looking for Robin to make sure that
she was okay and he actually manages to
convince GARP to not turn her in buds
actually let her Escape now this of
course gives him even more plus points
in Luffy's book than he already had who
then invites Robin to join the Marines
Garb and aokiji yell at him that that's
impossible however a short time later
Robin is instead picked up by the
revolutionaries and dragon although no
one knows who contacted them in the
first place now since they're on the
Marine ship this time around other than
the main storyline Luffy this time
simply passes by Jaya water 7 and
Thriller bark as a result Frankie is at
some point caught by zp9 while Brooke is
stuck in the Florian triangle for just a
little bit longer however he gets his
shadow back just a while later either
when Moria gets defeated at marineford
or when he tries to attack kaido in wano
once again and fails instead Luffy's
group manages to capture some
high-profile pirates with high bounties
testing out their new skills at this
point in the story Luffy's already able
to use haki and also use the techniques
of the six Powers now before they
finally reach Marine for it and the
headquarters they stop at Saba ODI
archipelago where where GARP wants to
introduce Luffy and the others to a
pirate called x-ray now Drake is one of
the few officially known members of the
secret sword organization and even
though Luffy and code don't know about
it quite yet GARP is already planning to
integrate all of them into sword as well
on the island Luffy also finds his way
into the slave auction house and is
absolutely appalled seeing the celestial
Dragons by human beings as slave reminds
him of the gray terminal and how the
Celestial Dragon sung Sabo ship back
then as well and so just like in the
main storyline Luffy's about to punch
the Celestial Dragon Charles when
Rayleigh makes his appearance using his
conquerors hockey he knocks out almost
all the people in the auction Hall and
takes Luffy and the others to his bar
there he introduces himself as Roger's
right-hand man and tells Luffy that he's
been waiting for him he tries to
convince Luffy to quit the Marines and
allow him to train him now Luffy has at
this Point experienced a number of
really heavy setbacks to his confidence
in the Marine organization but at that
moment where Luffy is actually
considering joining the Rayleigh GARP
comes crashing in through the door and
after a short and heated conversation
with Rayleigh holds Luffy back to his
ship with a quite tense atmosphere
finally they arrive at marineford where
Luffy Zorro Sanji Nami Chopper Kobe and
Hal mepo are all finally introduced to
sengoku kizuru and Akainu now Luffy does
like sengoku well enough and seems
neutral toward kizaru but it's clear
right from the start that he already has
a strong disliking for kainu for the way
that he talks and acts about Pirates
after that the next few weeks GARP and
other officers train the group hard and
send them on a number of small emissions
Luffy is even promoted to one of the
youngest captains in Marine history for
his incredible fighting abilities
however then news arrived at his brother
Ace has been captured by Blackbeard and
handed over to the government to be
executed and Luffy of course completely
snaps when he hears those news and it
takes garps and the rest of the squad's
collective effort to stop Luffy marching
straight to imple down by himself to
break Ace out instead Marine Ford starts
to prepare for war against whitebeards
now as a result of Luffy never coming to
save Ace the prison break from imple
down never happens Jim Bay doesn't
manage to escape from Level 6 either and
most importantly though without Luffy's
Great Escape creating a lot of chaos
Blackbeard's attempt to recruit the
level 6 Pirates backfires spectacularly
and he and his crew are defeated by a
Magellan now the war against Whitebeard
itself happens quite similarly to the
main timeline only that Luffy refuses to
fight at all now there are a few
different ways that this scenario could
go of course one option is that Luffy
just snaps and joins up with Whitebeard
to try and free Ace anyways we do know
that Luffy would do anything for his
brother so it's not all that unlikely
that he just throw his Marine career
aside to do the right thing but for the
sake of the story let's say that sengoku
or someone else stops Luffy from doing
anything when Ace is finally executed
executed by Akino of course for
continuity's sake which of course
absolutely breaks Luffy now Kobe and
Shanks stopped the war once again but
this time Shanks actually walks up to
Luffy and talks to him he tells Luffy
that he has the power to make the world
a better place and tells him to meet
Shanks in two years in the new worlds
after the war only slowly overcoming his
pain from losing Ace Luffy trains hard
for two years and finally GARP invites
all of his students to join swords Luffy
then takes the opportunity to meet up
with Shanks and joins his crew as an
undercover agent like Drake does with
kaido or aokiji with Blackbeard in the
main storyline shangs then trains Luffy
even more teaching him the truth about
his devil fruit the importance of
finding the one piece and reaching love
tale and at this point I would say that
Luffy either fully goes back to just
being a pirate and becoming pirate king
or he stays as a part of Sword reach his
love tail changes the world and actually
manages to become the fleet Admiral of a
marine organization that is free and
independent of the world governments
really at this point I think that Luffy
is just such a special person that even
as a marine he would still be able to
change the world so maybe a much better
question to ask would be what would
happen to the one piece world if Luffy
was never born in the first place
because that one is a lot darker
timeline than this one if you're curious
you can watch that one right here